هذا مات قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي مقهى
بمحتوياته تعود ملكيته للمواطن عوض ابو
صبيح في بلده بيت حنينا في القدس المحتله
قرارا بالمحكمه الاسرائيليه بتجميد عمليه
الهدم حتى يوم السبت المقبل حيث منحته
مهله لنهايه اجراءاته اصدار التراخيصه
لفتح المقهى واضافا ابو صبيح ان المحل
اقيم على ارضه الخاصه بالقرب من منزله
وكانت قوته الاحتلال هدمت في وقت سابق
مخزنا واساسيات ومنشات تجاريه في حي الحمص
في بلده صرب باهر
بالقدس المحتل رغم امتلاكه التراخيص
البناء
وفي بلده سلوى في بيت لحم هدمت قوات
الاحتلال منزل المواطن خليل عوض الله
مراسله الجزيره نجوان السمري تنضم الينا
من هناك والمشهد لديك نجوان
نعم مياده ربما الصوره تتحدث عن هذا الوضع
الماساوي لعائله ابو زيد خليل عوض الله من
قريه
جنوب غرب القدس المحتله هذه القريه تقع
تماما بين مدينتي القدس
وبيت لحم من جهه الغرب صباح هذا اليوم عند
السادسه فجرا رغم هذا الجو المطر والبارد
جدا اقتحمت قوات كبيره من قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي هذا الحي الحي يسمى حي عين
الجوزي في قريه
هذا المنزل دون اي انذار مسبق وشرعت
بعمليه الهدم لهذا البيت الذي انتقل اليه
العائله قبل النحو عام العائله كانت تسكن
في بيت الشده هو اب ولديه سبعه ابناء
وانتقلوا الى هذا البيت الذي بناه صاحب
المنزل قبل نحو عام في ارضه الخاصه وهمم
قاموا بهدمه تماما وشردوا العائله هذا
الحي باكمله مستهدف وهو يقع قريب جدا من
منطقه القدس وهناك اجراءات قامت بها بلديه
احتلال القدس لضم هذه المنطقه الى نفوذها
رغم انها تقع بالكامل داخل الضفه الغربيه
هذه القريه هي قريه فلسطينيه في حدود
الضفه الغربيه وتقع خلف الحاجز العسكري
الذي يفصل مدينه القدس عن امتدادها مع بيت
لحم لكن جزء من هذه القريه اعلنته سلطات
الاحتلال بانه تابع للنفوذ بلديه الاحتلال
وهناك ما يقارب 50 بيتا في هذا الحي معرضه
للهدم بعد ان تم تسليم اصحاب المنازل
اوامر بهدمها هناك جزء اخر من القريه يصنف
ضمن اا اراضي اا سيف في الدفاع الغربيه او
اراضي جي موفقه اتفاقيه اوسلو وهي المناطق
الخاضعه للضفه الغربيه ولكن سلطات
الاحتلال تسيطر على هذه المنطقه ااه
بالكامل ليس بعيدا من هنا ايضا مياده في
بلده بيت جالا القريبه من هنا كان هناك
هدم اخر لاحد الشباب الفلسطينيين في ارضه
ايضا منزل قيد البناء او بالاحرى في مرحله
الانتهاء جورج ان جورج همم قال بانهم ايضا
ذهبوا البيت رغم ان لديه امر تجميد من
المحكمه امر تجميد
قاموا بهدم منزله ايضا ضمن هذه الحمله
لهدم المنازل الفلسطينيه تندا لقرارات
المجلس الوزاري الامني السياسي المصغر
كالرد على العمليتين في مدينه القدس نشكرك
جزيلا شكرا سمري